hey guys Pete here what did you think
about the latest episode of mr. robot I
thought it was pretty good there was
some ups and downs as far as the
storytelling went but this will be my
recap and review for mr. robot season 3
episode 8 and we're gonna jump right
into it I mentioned in my last video my
last recap that episode 7 felt like the
end of the mini series that was jammed
in the middle there and this episode
felt like it needed to happen we know
this is three weeks after the events
that happened on 929 when the 71 Ecore
buildings were blown up and we know that
event and the deaths of Trenton and
Mobley have been weighing heavy on
Elliot since then stylistically I was
pretty well engaged the entire time and
I actually had some feelings about what
was happening the music was good the
change of pace wasn't too difficult to
get into but what I found most
impressive was something that I
mentioned in quite a few of my recaps
this season and that is the fact that we
know Eliot's not gonna kill himself but
the show did a good job of keeping us
interested anyways just to make that a
little bit more clear we are in the
third to last episode of the season and
we know that there's just no way that
Elliot's gonna kill himself so that he
can get rid of mr. robot but somehow I
didn't find myself being bothered with
that idea now the kid was a little bit
too much for me at times
Trenton's little brother I guess mostly
because it's a tried and true kind of
thing and you know that what's gonna
happen but I would say that Elliot Rami
Malik's acting here kind of
counterbalance that in that I still
didn't mind it as much as I may have in
another episode of another television
show I thought the drug dealer was a
little bit too over-the-top but it
wasn't a big part of the episode so it
was okay but I think what really worked
here is that we needed to get Elliot
turned around we needed him to accept
some things in order for him to move on
and move the story on and by the end of
the episode I think it accomplished its
goal doing that in the aftermath of the
929 tragedy Elliot basically gives up
takes three weeks and thinks about his
options and he decides that the only one
that really works is him committing
suicide he looks at everything that's
happened and he realizes that mr. robot
played a huge part in that and the only
person that can take him out is Elliott
himself and he tells Darlene he's tried
everything he's tried therapy he's tried
medication he had himself arrested
Darlene senses that Elliott's in the
dangerous spot but he turns her away he
tells her that she needs some time alone
but that she can come back tomorrow and
the watch the careful massacre of the
bush Ozzy together he pawned off flipper
to his neighbor he drops off to mr.
robot jacket at the trash burning center
there on the street and he goes and buys
a really large bag of morphine so that
he can go to Coney Island and end his
life on the way though he checks in with
the families of both Mobley and Trenton
Mowgli's brother is kind of a douche and
he lashes out saying that you know look
what he's done to my career and so on
and so forth she said he's not gonna pay
for a terrorist funeral and Trenton's
family is planning to leave the city and
maybe leave the country it's not a
hundred percent clear there but they're
scared because of their faith and the
fact that they might be attacked in
retribution for what happened Elliot
tells Trenton's father that she was a
good person and she never would have
done it what they're saying that she did
and while he's there her little brother
Mohammed overhears and he decides to
follow Elliot to the beach at first when
Elliot arrived at the beach I wasn't
entirely sure that we could trust what
we saw but it turns out that everything
was pretty straightforward as far as an
Elliot centric episode goes the kids
dealing with a major trauma that
happened in his life and he's trying to
find answers and he's grabbing on to
anything he can get old of Elliot was at
the wrong place at the right time if he
really wanted to try to kill himself
because now he has a companion as
mentioned the kid was a little bit too
much in that you could just it was
really telegraphed what was going to
happen and maybe it was a little bit
long all together as I
the sequence with those two together but
the things I liked about it was that we
see a parallel with Elliott we see that
his trauma as a child is what really
kind of makes him so awkward around
others so they have a real bond here and
there's also that this kid is a little
bit devious and Elliott picks up on it
but he doesn't mind so much he tricks
them into going to the movies they go
and they watch Back to the Future 2 it's
the anniversary day so there's a bunch
of cosplayers there and it kind of
lightened up the emotional tone I guess
definitely the cosplayers and the ice
cream man who's blaring war the worlds
as he's driving around instead of the
pleasant ice cream man music that you're
used to hearing from an ice-cream truck
and I feel like s Mel made himself a
little bit of a jab towards critics
whenever he talks about the Martian the
kid wants to see the Martian and how it
has a 92 percent on Rotten Tomatoes and
Elliott says that's because most critics
have bad taste I found myself wondering
if there's some sort of personal story
from Sam s mail here we know that he
grew up in New Jersey he was born into
an Egyptian family of Muslim faith they
moved around a bit before returning back
to Washington Township in New Jersey and
on top of Elliot's Redemption from his
suicide plot we also learned that
there's a pretty good chance that mr.
robot has been with Elliot since he was
a child we see in the very beginning a
flashback to them at the movies
Elliot still hasn't forgiven his father
for pushing him out the window which all
seems to be real at this point he's
being an angry kid he knows his dad's
sick but probably isn't expecting the
end to come so soon edward has him to
forgive him and he says no he collapses
in the lobby and then Elliot takes the
jacket goes into the movie theater and
we see him talk to somebody right away
right there and I think we're supposed
to think that that is the mr. robot
character
for the first time Elliott is presented
with the chance to make a difference in
Muhammad's life he leaves the movie
theater Elliot has to chase after him he
finds him at a mosque and he's able to
convince him that it's not his fault
that his sister died this allows
Muhammad to forgive himself and to be at
peace and it also gives Elliot a chance
to start forgiving himself the
culmination of this is when Mohammad
says I wish you were dead and Elliot
says so do I not my favorite turning
point of a conversation but it worked
okay I think and it gives Muhammad some
insight into what's going on with Elliot
although he's too young to really
understand what's going on like I said I
think that Rami mallets performance and
Muhammad's performance was actually
cooked quite good as well for the role I
think it salvaged the potentially cheesy
interaction between the two the theater
I thought was good with the idea that
these people who were back to the future
maniacs were all there I really liked
the point where he asked him what the
movies about and everybody had a
different opinion and as I mentioned
earlier I think that the music and the
pacing was really quite good as far as
giving you some connection to this
character who has been almost existing
as a troubled superhero in the last
episodes in season 3 whereas here he
becomes a human being again
and I'm excited to see what this is
setting up as far as how this season is
going to end that's another thing that
did stand out to me here is we really
don't know where it's going at this
point and all we can tell for sure is
that Elliot is now trying to focus on
what he can fix rather than what he
can't so he visits Angela she still
seems to be completely whacked out and
he gets really human he gets to be a
real friend with her there and he talks
about when they were kids and the
swishing game they used to play and it's
a nice parallel you know wishing and
striving and trying to imagine a better
future is a lot better than just being
numb and going along with the
tene and pain that life can bring along
with it the mr. robot jacket comes back
I didn't really know I mean it was it
was kind of cool I guess
flipper is back that's good and we see
him put together a new machine after
being out and he gets the email from
Trenton with instructions on how they
could possibly undo the 5/9 hack and we
have a direction to go which if you read
her email to him
Romero did some things that could be key
to an undoing the five nine pack but
they're probably gonna have to hack the
FBI so let me know what you guys thought
in the comments did you enjoy this
episode or was it a little bit too
pulled back from where we were at just a
couple episodes ago what do you think's
gonna happen now that he's turned a
corner and he's moving forward and one
thing that is bugging me right now is
are we just supposed to believe that
they are free to roam like there's
nothing else that's gonna happen as far
as the FBI is concerned he said to
Darlene we get to get out of everything
for free and all that it just seems kind
of unlikely that they did what they did
and the FBI knows what they did and now
their deal is going to let them be free
and clear please like the video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already make sure
you click on that bell so you get
notifications for my next video when
it's uploaded follow me on Twitter and
you can also follow me on Instagram and
Facebook like my Facebook page thanks
for watching guys I'll talk to you soon